Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello and welcome to The Rest is History, the podcast that's not afraid to tackle the really big themes in under an hour. And today's theme is a truly massive one. The history of China, 4,000 years old, an empire as much as it is a nation state, and today returning inexorably, it would seem, to the status it enjoyed for centuries in the past as the greatest power on the face of the planet. And yet for all its fascination, its brilliance, its importance, it's a story that we in the West tend not to know much about. With me here is my co-conspirator Dominic Sandbrook. And Dominic, you and I, we did an
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。如需每周独家番外、无广告收听、系列节目抢先体验，以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。您好，欢迎收听《历史的余烬》，这是一个敢于在不到一小时内探讨真正宏大主题的播客。今天的主题极其宏大。中国历史，拥有4000年历史，它既是一个民族国家，也是一个庞大的帝国；而今天，它似乎不可阻挡地重回其在过去几个世纪里享有的地位——地球上最伟大的强权。然而，尽管它如此迷人、辉煌且重要，但对于身处西方的我们来说，这却是一个我们往往知之甚少的历史故事。与我一同录音的是我的老搭档多米尼克·桑德布鲁克。多米尼克，你和我之前做过一次
interview for GQ, didn't we, about this podcast. And you were asked the question, what is the field of history you know least about? And you said China. So obviously, we've got to do an episode on this. It's extraordinary though, isn't it? I was thinking today just before doing this, you know, I know Mao, and I have some vague sense of the 20th century. But before that, I'm not convinced I could name a single Chinese ruler or politician. I think that's true of a lot of people. It's just a sort of blur. So we needed somebody top dollar, didn't we, Tom, to help us? We absolutely did. And I think one of my favourite lockdown reads in the first lockdown was a book called The Story of China,
关于这个播客的GQ杂志采访，对吧？当时有人问你：“你对哪个历史领域的了解最少？”你回答说是中国。所以很显然，我们必须做一期关于中国的节目。不过这很不可思议，不是吗？就在做这期节目之前我还在想，我了解毛泽东，对20世纪也有一些模糊的概念。但在那之前，我不确信自己能否说出任何一个中国统治者或政治家的名字。我想很多人都有同感。这就像是一片模糊。所以我们需要一位顶级的大咖来帮帮我们，对吧，汤姆？当然需要。而且我想我在第一次封城期间最喜欢的读物之一，就是《中国的故事》
a Portrait of Civilisation and Its People by one of my all time heroes, Michael Wood. So I got on to Michael, asked him if he would come on and help us deal with this huge topic. And I'm delighted to say that he he said yes. So, Michael, thanks so much for joining us. It's a real pleasure to be with you. Such a great podcast you do. I hope I can help. As you know, the more that you discover about China, the more you realise, the less you know.
——一部文明及其人民的写照，作者是我心目中的英雄之一迈克尔·伍德。于是我联系了迈克尔，问他是否愿意来和我们一起探讨这个宏大的主题。我很高兴地说，他答应了。所以，迈克尔，非常感谢你加入我们。很高兴能和你们在一起。你们做了一个这么棒的播客。希望能帮到你们。如你们所知，你对中国了解得越多，就会越发意识到自己知道得越少。
Well, you know more, definitely know more about it than either of us. So could we, we've got a very interesting question i think to kick off with um because obviously we are all of us um european um so we're from the far end of the world but we've got a question here from gregory doyle and he asks what is the historical event in their history that is most important to the chinese themselves and then he also says what dominic and I've been saying, I'm amazed at my own ignorance of their history, except for Mongol invasions and communism. So do you have a sense of that? Wow. Well, that is a fantastic question.
好吧，你对它的了解绝对比我们俩都要多。所以，我们有一个非常有趣的问题想开个头，因为显然我们所有人都是欧洲人，来自世界的另一端。我们这里有一个来自格雷戈里·多伊尔的问题，他问：在他们自己的历史中，对中国人自己来说最重要的历史事件是什么？然后他还说，这和多米尼克我俩刚才说的一样，除了蒙古入侵和共产主义，我对自己历史知识的匮乏感到震惊。所以你对此有什么看法吗？哇。这是一个非常棒的问题。
Thanks, Gregory. I actually did a Vox Pops in the middle of a big exhibition at the Shanghai Expo, just asking ordinary Chinese tourists this question a few years ago. And it was really, really interesting. I mean, not least because nobody said the Chinese Revolution of 1949. I couldn't believe that. Everybody, you ask them about their favorite time or dynasty in Chinese history, and most people said the Tang Dynasty, which is like the age of Beowulf in Britain, you know, from the 600s to the 900s. And you say, why? And they go, well, you know, it's the culture, it's the civilization, it's our poetry. We still love the poetry of that time. They're our favorite poets. And it's also when China went out to the world. We were a great civilization, but we went out to the world,
谢谢格雷戈里。几年前，我在上海世博会的一次大型展览中做过一次街头随机采访，向普通的中国游客问过这个问题。真的非常非常有趣。原因之一是，竟然没有人说是1949年的中国革命。我简直不敢相信。你问他们最喜欢的中国历史时期或朝代是哪一个，大多数人都会说是唐代，这就像是英国的贝奥武夫时代，也就是公元7世纪到10世纪。你问他们为什么，他们会说，文化、文明、我们的诗歌。我们依然热爱那个时代的诗歌，他们是我们最喜爱的诗人。那也是中国走向世界的时期。我们是一个伟大的文明，但我们走向了世界，
and the world came to China. So in terms of a time, that's the favorite thing. But when you ask them, but what about an event? The most interesting answers were the opium wars and the beginning yeah now i think this i think this is influenced by what they learn at school because then what's called national studies at school in china still has this narrative but um you know the opium war ham the the wicked foreigners laid the nation low, the century of humiliation, the unequal treaties, all of which was redeemed by the Communist Party.
世界也走进了中国。所以在时间段方面，这是人们最喜欢的。但如果你问他们，那么哪个事件最重要？最有趣的回答是鸦片战争及其开始。是的，我认为这受到了他们在学校里学到的知识的影响，因为在中国，学校里所谓的“国民教育”仍然保留着这种叙事。不过，鸦片战争、万恶的外国列强使国家陷入衰落、百年耻辱、不平等条约，这一切都被中国共产党所挽救。
And now the China dream and the recovery of China sort of comes out of that. So coupled with that, a lot of people said, well, the Opium Wars and the Center of Humiliation were the events that triggered it. But what we all think now is the China dream, you know, that we've recovered. We've become the great nation again in the world and that there's food on our tables. And I actually phoned a friend of mine to ask her about her mom, who still lives in rural Hunan. And the mom said, you don't understand what it was like for us as children during the Great Famine and everything else. If you understood that, you'd understand why we feel the way we do.
现在，中国梦和中国的复兴某种程度上正是从这些历史中脱胎而出的。因此，结合这一点，很多人会说：“鸦片战争和耻辱中心是引发这一切的事件。”但我们现在普遍认为的是中国梦，即我们已经复兴了，我们再次成为了世界上的伟大国家，我们的餐桌上有饭吃。事实上，我还给我的一个朋友打过电话，向她打听她依然住在湖南农村的母亲。她母亲说：“你们根本不明白我们在大饥荒和其他事情中作为孩子时的感受。如果你能理解这一点，你就会理解我们为什么会有现在的感受。”
And that leads on to the final thing that comes out of all this is the opening up 40 years ago under Deng Xiaoping. And all of them say that that was the key that triggered the growth of modern China, everything that's happened since. And I asked the same question when I was doing some interviews a couple of years ago to one or two great American experts in this. People who'd been through it all, you know, the revolution and everything else, and looking back as older people. And the answer from them was that the greatest event in Chinese history was the opening up of 1978-79.
这就引出了所有人得出的最后一点，那就是40年前在邓小平领导下的改革开放。所有人都说，那是触发现代中国崛起以及之后发生的一切的关键。几年前我在做一些采访时，把同样的问题问了一两位美国顶尖的中国问题专家。他们是经历过这一切（包括革命及其他所有风浪）并在年老时回首往事的人。他们的回答是，中国历史上最伟大的事件是1978至1979年的改革开放。
Wow. And it's one of the greatest events in the history of the world. So that was the, so that's the matrix of ideas. Nobody picks on 1949, interestingly enough. That is true. And in my frustration, finally, you know, in response to what Tom said, you know, you're going to come on, guys, you know, we've got 4,000 years of history here.
哇。这也是世界历史上最伟大的事件之一。这就是他们的思想矩阵。有趣的是，没有人选择1949年。确实如此。最后，为了表达我的沮丧（作为对汤姆之前的话的回应），你知道的：“你们要来聊这个，我们这里有四千年的历史啊。
We can't be, you know, come on, guys, you know, we've got 4,000 years of history here. We can't be, you know, 1978. And my Chinese friend, Tina, said, well, I said, there must be something else. And she said, well, all right, Qin Shi Huangdi and the unification of China in the third century BC. Yes. So there's your spread of ideas. Impossible to give you give you one mike have you seen have you seen the film hero you must have seen it yeah yeah fantastic fantastic but but kind of a sinister as well in a way dominic have you seen it no i haven't tell me
我们不能只——拜托，伙计们，我们这里有四千年的历史啊。我们不能只盯着——1978年。”而我的中国朋友蒂娜说：“好吧，”我说，“肯定还有别的东西。”她说：“好吧，秦始皇和公元前三世纪中国的统一。”是的。这就是你们的想法范围。不可能只给你一个答案。迈克尔，你看过电影《英雄》吗？你肯定看过吧？对，对，非常棒，非常棒。但某种程度上也带有一点阴暗色彩，多米尼克，你看过吗？没有，我没看过。快告诉我
about it it's about a team of assassins who are sent to kill the emperor of chin um and then it turns out that they've recognised that destiny requires the Emperor of Qin to live so that he can found China and it will become a great power. But I think, Michael, the point of that was very fairly squarely aimed at Taiwan and Tibet and separatists generally. And that kind of sense of a nexus that the beginnings of China and China's status now are kind of bound up. And I just wonder when we talk about China, are we talking about a continuum? Or are we talking actually about a succession of different empires, different states that just happen to occupy the same geographical space, do you think?
讲的是什么。讲的是一队刺客被派去刺杀秦王，然后他们发现，命运要求秦王活下来，这样他才能创立中国，让中国成为一个强大的国家。不过我认为，迈克尔，这其实是把矛头直接指向了台湾、西藏和一般的分裂分子。那种中国初创时期的合法性与中国现在的地位紧密相连的潜台词。我就在想，当我们谈论中国时，我们是在谈论一个连续体吗？还是说，我们实际上是在谈论一连串不同的帝国、不同的国家，它们只是恰好占据了相同的地理空间？你觉得呢？
Yeah, it's a really interesting question. And it is a continuum, really. Somebody once said that when history in the West, people view history as being the succession of different empires and different civilizations from Rome and Greece and, you know, Assyria and Egypt and the Carolingian, different. Whereas in China, it's the succession of, it's the rhythm of one civilization. Whereas in the West, it's a cycle of many different civilizations. I mean, you could argue, and reading your book, Tom, you could argue that Western Latin Christendom constitutes a civilization. Don't encourage it, Michael.
是的，这是一个非常有趣的问题。它确实是一个连续体。曾有人说过，在西方，人们将历史视为不同帝国和文明的更替——从罗马、希腊、亚述、埃及到卡洛林王朝，等等。而在中国，它是一种文明的延续和节奏。但在西方，这是一个多种不同文明的循环。当然你可以认为——读了你的书，汤姆，你也可以认为——西方拉丁基督教世界构成了一个单一的文明。别鼓励他，迈克尔。
A single civilization which has risen and fallen and whatever. But in China, it's a continuum. And they're very conscious of that. You know, you get these guys in the terrible breakdown after the Tang Dynasty in the 10th century saying, you know, a new China will arise. Will we reconstitute the kingdom? The beginning of the most famous, one of the most famous novels in China, the Romance of the Three Kingdoms, begins with a line which roughly says, it is a truth universally acknowledged that every empire
一个曾经兴衰更迭的单一文明。但在中国，这是一个连续体，他们对此有着清醒的认识。你知道，唐朝在10世纪经历可怕的崩溃后，那些人会说：“一个新的中国将会崛起，我们会重建王国吗？”中国最著名的小说之一《三国演义》开篇就有一句大致这样的话：“话说天下大势，分久必合，合久必分。”所以，这是一个连续体。
that falls apart will come together again, and that every empire that is united will fall apart you know so so so it's a it's a continuum and just just to pick up on what you said about today i mean it's a really key part plank of the president she's um regime you know they've got to deliver growth if you look at the planks they've got to deliver growth because public opinion will only stick with them with what they're doing. So that's an important aspect of it. But national studies are really important to them now. And President Xi is constantly harping on about the greatness of the Chinese past. And when you look at Qin Shi Huangdi, the first emperor in the third century, I mean, the Qin Empire only lasted about 10 years and was overthrown because it was
顺便回应一下你刚才关于当今局势的看法，这确实是习近平主席政权执政方针的关键支柱。他们必须兑现经济增长，如果你看看他们的政策支柱，他们必须实现增长，因为公众舆论只有在他们有所作为的情况下才会支持他们。所以这是很重要的一个方面。此外，“国学”对他们来说也非常重要。习近平主席经常谈论中国过去的伟大。当你审视三世纪的秦始皇时，秦朝其实只存在了大约十年，由于深遭人民痛恨而被推翻。
so hated by the people, you know. But the legacy of it is emblematic to the Chinese. And the ideas that underwrote the Qin Empire were legalist ideas by this political philosopher called Lord Shang, who wrote this book of Lord Shang. And it argues for an absolutely repressive, clamped-down state where every person is itemised in the kind of population lists and where cruel punishments are. It's a really strict legalist order without Confucian humanism. And actually, President Xi not long ago did a speech in which he dropped in one of the legalist philosophers as being, you know, these ideas are still part of our being. Let me just ask you a question following up what you were saying about, you know, dynasties rising and falling and stuff. Why is China so big and why has it always been so big so why have successive dynasties been able to
但它的遗产对中国人来说具有象征意义。支撑秦朝的思想是政治哲学家商鞅的法家思想，他写了《商君书》。它主张建立一个绝对镇压、铁腕统治的国家，其中每个人都在户籍名单中被登记在册，并实行残酷的刑罚。这是一种没有儒家仁本主义的、极其严格的法家秩序。事实上，不久前习近平主席发表了一次讲话，其中提到了某位法家哲学家，称这些思想仍然是我们生命的一部分。接着你刚才谈到的朝代兴衰之类的话题，我想问你一个问题：为什么中国这么大？为什么它一直都这么大？为什么历代王朝能够将它们的统治强加于如此广袤的领土和如此庞大的人口？相比之下，西方的四分五裂——你刚才提到汤姆关于西方基督教世界的观点，即西方基督教世界一直无法统一——为什么中国能作为一个如此巨大的实体存续下来？
impose their rule on such an enormous territory and such a huge number of people compared with the fragmentation of you know you mentioned tom's idea about western christendom that western christendom has been impossible to unite why Why has China survived as such an enormous entity? Yeah, it's such an interesting question, isn't it? Because there's plenty of points in Chinese history, like in the 10th century, where China broke apart. There were 16 different dynasties during that early part of the 10th century, including five major kingdoms with civil services and everything else.
是的，这真是一个非常有趣的问题，不是吗？因为在中国历史上有很多时期，比如10世纪，中国曾分崩离析。10世纪初有16个不同的朝代，包括五个拥有官僚机构及其他体制的主要王国。
But the drive was to come back to this concept of unity and that lies very deep in you know confucius's idea about this culture of ours we're defending han speech handwriting and customs and and that um that that's the difference with with europe i think i mean when you look at the size of China, though, if you look at the maps, it expands and then it contracts, almost like a living organism. And you look at the Song Dynasty, for example, 10th, 11th centuries, one of the greatest civilizations that had ever existed
但驱使人们回归的动力是这种统一的观念，这深深植根于——比如孔子关于“我们的文化”的观念，我们在捍卫汉族的语言、书写和习俗。这就是与欧洲的不同之处，我想。如果你看看中国的疆域大小，看地图的话，它会扩张，然后又收缩，几乎就像一个有生命的有机体。看看宋朝，10、11世纪，地球上曾经存在过的最伟大的文明之一，在科学、技术、文学、印刷术等各个方面，可能直到那个时期都是最伟大、最先进的，
on the face of the earth, probably the greatest and most advanced till that point in terms of science technology literature printing everything you know and but it's only the heartland of china you know that kind of circular land that is encompassed by the two rivers in the plain you know and then you get other periods for instance the qin dynasty from the well let's take the qing dynasty as the one that's closest to us in the from the 17th century to 1911 and they conquer mongolia xinjiang and tibet and that that picture that we have in our minds of the map of today's china is really the product of that. You know, the Ming, the Song, they ruled the heartland of China, you know, China proper.
然而它仅仅是中国的核心地带，也就是那片被两条河流和平原环绕的环形土地。然后你会看到其他时期，例如清朝——我们离得最近的朝代，从17世纪到1911年，他们征服了蒙古、新疆和西藏。我们脑海中今天中国的地图画面，实际上就是这个时期的产物。明朝、宋朝，他们统治的只是中国的核心地带，也就是传统的“汉地”。
And the Chinese today, of course, with their very aggressive nationalistic policies, they really don't like the idea that what is now China was the product of imperial expansion over peoples who are not Chinese. And American academics who've recently written a couple of books on Xinjiang and on the Chinese expansion under the Qing, they were barred from doing public events in China, book events, even after their books had been in a cut form, printed in China, because the Chinese like to insist that these are an inviolable part of the motherland, when of course
当然，今天的中国推行着非常具有侵略性的民族主义政策，他们真的不喜欢这样一种观点：现在所谓的中国，其实是对非汉族人民进行帝国扩张的产物。一些美国学者最近写了几本关于新疆以及清朝中国扩张的书，他们在中国的公共活动和图书活动被禁，甚至在他们的书经过删减在中国出版后也是如此，因为中国人喜欢坚信这些是祖国不可分割的一部分，但事实当然并非如此。
they're not. You know, Tibet had been an independent kingdom for most of its existence. So why is it so big is an interesting question. They went out under the Han dynasty in the time of the Roman Republican Empire into Xinjiang with the Silk Road and forts going out west to link up with Central Asia and beyond. They went out the same time in the late 600s under the Tang dynasty. But the essential core of Chinese civilization is much, much smaller. And what you look at today is really the aftermath of imperial expansion over non-Chinese peoples. And those non-Chinese peoples are still aggrieved at that, hence the terrible suppression happening at the moment in Xinjiang.
你知道，西藏在其存在的大部分时间里都是一个独立的王国。所以，为什么它这么大，这是一个有趣的问题。早在汉代和罗马共和国时期，他们就沿着丝绸之路进入新疆，建立前哨基地向西延伸，与中亚及更远地区建立联系。在6世纪末的唐朝，他们也曾向外拓展。但中国文明的核心本质要小得多。你今天看到的，实际上是对非中国本土民族进行帝国扩张后的遗留产物。而那些非中国本土民族至今仍对此感到不满，因此新疆目前才发生了可怕的镇压。
And those heartlands are based around rivers. Yeah. Essentially. So it's like you have an amazing, one of my favourite sentences in your book, I've copied it out here, when you're talking about Qing China, so 18th century,
这些核心地带基本上都是围绕着河流展开的。对，基本上是这样。所以就像你书中有一句我最喜欢的句子，我把它抄录在这里，当你在谈论清朝（即18世纪）时，
it was as if pharaonic Egypt had come through to the 18th century, still worshipping Amun, its bureaucracy still skilled in hieroglyphs, while having invented the steam engine and Euclidean mathematics centuries before Europe. And I love it because it does convey that sense of an ancient civilization lasting into the present day. It's kind of like the computer game Civilization where
那情景就好像法老时代的埃及一直延续到了18世纪，依然在崇拜阿蒙神，其官僚机构依然精通象形文字，同时却在欧洲之前几个世纪就发明了蒸汽机和欧几里得几何学。我非常喜欢这句话，因为它确实传达了一种古老文明一直延续到当代的厚重感。这有点像电脑游戏《文明》里，
the Romans invent skyscrapers and things. So what are the features of Chinese civilization that we can trace through the centuries that enable us to talk about there being continuity despite the kind of bust ups and barbarian invasions and so on? Is it the sense of an emperor? Is it Confucianism? And how far back does that reach? Does it reach back before the time of the first emperor? Well, I think most experts would say it's very interesting when you read scholars writing in the 1950s, Western scholars looking at what was happening under Mao, and all of them, these distinguished sinologists are saying that it's eerily, uncannily replicating the centralized authoritarian bureaucracies that you saw in the imperial period, you know, under the Ming and the Qing,
罗马人发明了摩天大楼之类的东西。那么，我们可以通过哪些历经数个世纪追踪到的中国文明特征，来证明尽管经历了种种动荡和蛮族入侵等，中国依然存在延续性呢？是因为有一种皇帝的概念吗？是儒家思想吗？这可以追溯到多远？它能追溯到第一位皇帝之前吗？好吧，我想大多数专家都会说，很有趣的是，当你阅读20世纪50年代学者的著作时，那些研究毛泽东时代西方学者都在说，这简直诡异、不可思议地复制了你在帝国时期（即明清时期）看到的中央集权式威权官僚体制，
you know, that the communists actually going back to a Chinese template. And I mean, they're trying to reform, they're trying to change the countryside and have, you know, agricultural communes and all that. But essentially, it's that all-controlling authoritarian bureaucracy. So a centralized bureaucratic empire is a key thing. The position of the emperor is very interesting. There's been a lot of work by scholars at the moment on this idea of the sage emperor and this figure who ultimately power and authority goes back to him. And the emperor must
也就是说，共产党实际上是在回归中国的历史模板。当然，他们试图进行改革，试图改变农村并建立农业公社等等，但从本质上讲，这就是那种全能控制的威权官僚体制。因此，中央集权的官僚帝国是一个关键要素。皇帝的地位非常有趣。目前学者们围绕着“圣君”的概念以及权力与权威最终归于这一形象的理念进行了大量研究。皇帝必须
be wise and all seeing. And when you look at how that was transferred to the cult of Mao and how Mao was adulated, as you know, all rivers flow to the sea and all the Chinese people flow to you, great leader, you know, as the sun shines you, this, you're ineffable, you know, the publicity, the peaking radio, you listen to all this stuff. It's unbelievable. So Mao really took on board that cult of the emperor. So there's that. There's the Confucian ethic, of course, which really was,
英明神武且洞察一切。当你观察这种理念是如何被转移到对毛泽东的个人崇拜中时，毛泽东是如何受到崇拜的——正如你所知，“万水朝东”、“全国人民向您汇聚，伟大领袖”，如同太阳照耀般，你那高深莫测的形象，那些宣传，北京人民广播电台，你听所有这些内容，简直难以置信。所以毛泽东确实继承了这种皇帝崇拜。这就是其中一点。当然，还有儒家伦理。孔子生活在大约公元前500年，
Confucius lived about 500 BC, you know, same time as a Buddha and the great figures in Greece. And his ethos, he was a total failure in his lifetime. But his ethos was adopted by later dynasties. And there's always a balance in Chinese history between the authoritarian, legalist, punishment-based, pretty ferocious bureaucracy and the humanist ideas of Confucius, which are very conformist in their ways. I mean, a lot of people in the 20th century republic were saying, we've got to get rid of all this stuff because it's cannibalising our children. It's still in hock to this subservient, ritual-based, you know. But in the best periods of Chinese history, this humanist idea was capable of great reinvention, you know. So what is the humanist idea?
跟佛陀和希腊的伟大人物处于同一时期。他的理念在生前完全是个失败，但他的理念被后来的朝代所采纳。在中国历史上，威权、法家、基于惩罚的严厉官僚体制，与孔子崇尚顺从的人文主义思想之间，始终存在着一种平衡。在20世纪的共和国时期，很多人说：“我们必须摆脱所有这些东西，因为它在吞噬我们的儿童。它依然受制于这种顺从的、基于礼仪的……”但在中国历史的最好时期，这种人文主义思想能够实现巨大的重塑。那么，什么是人文主义思想？
When you say humanist, what's the essence of it? Well, you know, these are complicated things, and I think I'm probably not qualified to talk about them but but um uh you know the works which purport to be those confucius which are written down by his pupils uh contain all kinds of ideas about uh you know justice and um all people being equal or men being brothers, that we have to have a society where the actions of the ruler are based on virtue and civility, and great rulership must adhere to these principles. And if a ruler is tyrannical,
当你提到人文主义时，它的本质是什么？嗯，你知道，这些都很复杂，我想我可能没有资格谈论它们。不过，那些被认为是孔子言论、由其弟子记录下来的著作中，包含了各种关于正义的观点，
then the people have a right to rise against him. So it's a system of civil order. He's not interested in gods. He's not interested in the afterlife. He never talks about the afterlife. He's interested in how we have a balanced civil life on earth. He didn't doubt, of course, the figure of the great ruler, but the great ruler must act according to virtue.
比如所有人都是平等的，或者四海之内皆兄弟，我们必须建立一个社会，在这个社会中，统治者的行为基于美德和礼貌，而伟大的统治必须恪守这些原则。如果一个统治者是暴君，
But that sense of civility and the way you are and deference and all that, you talk about what survived until the present day. On another dimension, anybody who's travelled in China and actually spent time with the Chinese people, we have a funny idea of the Chinese people. Everybody thinks there's a rather cool attitude to them and frosty at the moment, and the Chinese people. Everybody thinks there's a rather cool attitude to them and frosty at the moment, and the Chinese people are caught up in all this.
那么人民就有权反抗他。所以这是一个维护公民秩序的系统。他不关心神明，不关心来世，他从不谈论来世，他关心的是我们如何在地球上过上平衡的公民生活。当然，他并不怀疑伟大统治者的形象，但伟大的统治者必须按美德行事。以及那种文明的感召力、你待人接物的方式以及恭顺等等，你谈到了那些延续至今的事物。从另一个维度来看，任何去过中国并真正花时间与中国人民相处过的人，我们对中国人民其实有一个有趣的印象。每个人都认为目前对他们有一种相当冷淡、冰冷态度，
But actually, anybody who travels in China, you know how affable and sociable Chinese people are. They love being in society. They love eating together. They have to rub along together because there's so many of them. In the heartland of China, it's very, very densely populated. So you have to have a sense of the collective. And I think the sense of the collective is very, very important to China.
而中国人民似乎都卷入了这一切之中。但实际上，任何去中国旅行过的人都知道中国人民是多么随和、多么善于社交。他们喜欢置身于社群之中，喜欢聚餐。他们必须和平相处，因为人口实在太多了。在中国腹地，人口非常非常稠密。所以你必须有一种集体意识。我认为集体意识对中国来说非常非常重要。
You look at their response to the COVID outbreaks and the way that people, obviously, they were told by the government they had to obey the rules, but people obeyed the rules and helped their neighbours and set up neighbourhood committees and everything else. It's not just the Communist Party running it. There's a deep sense of the collective. So I would say there's the big political picture and there's the social picture of how Chinese people are together. And that solidarity is a very, very powerful thing. Michael, we need to get in some of the questions from the public, from the punters. And one of the big ones is this question about what happened to China. So why didn't China become a world power earlier? So Alan Allport asks, why after the
看看他们对新冠疫情爆发的反应，以及人们——显然，政府告诉他们必须服从规则，但人们不仅服从了规则，还帮助邻居、成立社区委员会等等。这不仅仅是由共产党在运营，其中有着深厚的集体意识。所以我想说，这里既有宏大的政治图景，也有中国人民如何相处的社会图景。这种团结是一种非常非常强大的力量。迈克尔，我们需要讨论一些来自公众、来自听众的问题。其中一个最大的问题是关于中国发生了什么。为什么中国没有更早成为世界大流？所以艾伦·奥尔波特问，为什么在郑和——希望我发音准确——的远航之后，中国放弃了相较于西方的全球探索优势？马克·伍德豪斯问，中国进行帝国扩张的能力究竟有多强？中国曾长期居于领先地位，然后是什么出了问题？为什么他们转向内向了？好吧，如果你把这个问题抛给15世纪的一个儒家官僚，当他们在郑和七次下西洋（曾到达东非和波斯湾）之后取消了后续的所有航海时，
voyages of Zheng He, I hope I'm pronouncing that correctly, to China give up its global exploratory advantage over the West. And Mark Woodhouse says, how capable were China of imperial expansion? So China was so preeminent for so long. And then what went wrong? Why did they turn inwards? Well, if you'd ask that of a Confucian bureaucrat in the 15th century, when they cancelled any more voyages after the Zheng He seven voyages, you know, when they'd gone to East Africa and the Persian Gulf. I mean, it wasn't the first time the Chinese ships had been out there.
他们会说：“你们说的扩张能力是什么意思？那不是我们文明的目标。我们文明的目标是耕耘中国的土地，为这庞大的人口维持一个公正的秩序，确保每个人都有饭吃，并让官僚机构、领导层和学术界去修炼内心世界、科学以及其他一切。走出去征服其他人，从来不是我们作为一个文明的目标。”
They would have said, what do you mean capable of expansion? That's not the goal of our civilization. The goal of our civilization is to cultivate the soil of China, to maintain a just order for this enormous population, to make sure that everybody's fed, and for the bureaucracy and the leadership and the scholarly world to cultivate the inner world and the sciences and everything else. It is not our aim as a civilization to go out and conquer other people.
在耶稣会传教士利玛窦的日记中有一段极其有趣的文字。他在1580年代来到中国，并在中国度过了余生，他的日记保存了下来。利玛窦说，东西方之间，即欧洲国家与中国国家之间，可以进行非常有趣的比较。在西方，人们总是焦躁不安，对自己拥有的一切永不满足，必须走出去夺取他国的土地。然而这根本不是中国文明的目标。我认为这是一个非常有趣的客观历史事实，尽管像唐朝和汉朝这样的帝国
And there's a fantastically interesting passage in the diary of the Jesuit, Matteo Ricci, who went in the 1580s to China and lived the rest of his life in China. And his diary survives. And Ricci says there are very interesting comparisons to be made between East and West, between the countries of Europe and the countries of China. But in the West, they are never, they are restless, and never satisfied with what they've got and have to go out and seize the lands of other people. Whereas this is not the goal of Chinese civilization at all. And I think, I think that's a very interesting historical fact, although, of course, empires like the Tang and the Han
确实曾沿着丝绸之路向外拓展并建立基地，但他们并不是为了征服其他国家而走出去的。这是因为他们太富有了吗？是因为有所谓的“高水平均衡陷阱”一说，即他们活得太安逸了吗？你可以做个对比。我的意思是，你曾做过一个关于征服者的系列节目。他们来自那些贫瘠的、
had gone out along the Silk Road and established their bases, but they hadn't gone out to conquer other countries. Is that because they were too rich? Is that because there's this talk of the high-level equilibrium trap, that they were sort of too comfortable? So you compare that. I mean, you did a series about the conquistadors. They were coming from scrubby, you know,
西班牙西部没有什么钱的小镇，为了发财而走出去。中国人是不是因为过得太好而没有这样做？好吧，当他们的船只驶向东非和类似地方时，他们可能并没有想过要去征服，他们可能会觉得：“好吧，去就去了。”但这并不在他们的思维模式中。尽管人们对郑和下西洋略有误解，我想。
towns in sort of Western Spain where there wasn't much money to make their fortune. Were the Chinese just too well off to do the same? Well, it probably didn't occur to them to, you know, when their ships went to East Africa and places like that, they probably thought, well, you know, do it. But it wasn't in their mindset to do that. Although the jungle voyages are slightly misunderstood, I think.
上周我听了大卫·阿布拉菲亚关于海洋的书，他仍然有点坚持认为中国人这些伟大的远航中只是在“秀旗帜”。而我认为现代学术研究表明，他们真正试图做的是巩固和保护贸易路线，并在巨港以及印度尼西亚的类似地方建立基地。这些行动是有其目的的，就像明朝外交使团前往中亚有其目的的一样。所以，你知道，他们比我们想象的更具务实精神。但走出去征服其他国家并不是他们的目标。这是对这个非常有趣的问题的第一个回答。如果你回顾10、11、12世纪的宋朝，很显然，在科学技术方面，他们是当时最先进的文明。
I was listening to David Abelafia's book about the oceans the other week, and he still slightly hung on to the idea that the Chinese were just showing the flag in these great expeditions. Whereas I think all the modern scholarships suggest that what they were trying to do was really pin down and protect trade routes and establish bases in Palembang and places like that in Indonesia. And there was a purpose behind these, just as there was a purpose to the Ming Dynasty diplomatic expeditions into Central Asia. So, you know, they were more practically minded, I think, than we think. But it wasn't their goal to go out and conquer other nations. That's the first thing in answer to this very interesting question. And if you look back at the 10th, 11th, 12th century under the Song, quite, you know, clearly they were the most advanced civilization in terms of science and technology.
也就是火药、街灯、所有这些技术。海军技术。印刷术。他们比其他任何人都走得更远，你看。但去征服其他国家并不在他们的思维模式中。事实上，在11世纪，他们与中国本土大地上其他强大的王国（如辽国）共享这片土地，但他们通过谨慎的外交、建立良好关系、
So that's gunpowder, streetlights, all that. Naval technology. Printing. They were further ahead than anyone else, you see. But it wasn't in their mindset to go and conquer other countries. In fact, they shared the landmass of China, what is today the landmass of China, with other powerful kingdoms in the 11th century, like the Georgian, but they established an equilibrium by careful diplomacy and establishing good relations
定期互派使节访问邻国来建立平衡。所以他们——事实上，到了12世纪，宋朝在许多方面已经蓄势待发，你甚至可以说它将成为第一个现代国家，因为在政治组织、经济和财政政策等所有这些方面，他们都远为先进。我的意思是，当威廉征服者在1066年战役后毁灭诺森布里亚时，王安石和中国的宰相们正坐在那里思考税收水平、填平贫富差距、缩小贫富鸿沟。你知道，我们该怎么处理……他们正把这些学者召集起来说：“我们必须为这些能够提升人民生活的地区制定经济政策。
and having regular visits to the courts of their neighbours and all that sort of stuff. So they were, and actually the Song dynasty by the 1100s was in many ways poised you would have said to become the first modern nation because in terms of political organization you know economic and financial policy and all this they were they were much more advanced i mean the time william the conquerors devastating northumbria in the aftermath of 1066, Wang Anxue and the Chinese council are sitting there thinking about, you know, taxation levels and evening the evening up the leveling up the equality gap. You know, what are we going to do with, you know, and they're getting this all theuses in and they're saying, we've got to have an economic policy for these regions that lifts the people up, you know.
我们不能让这样一个社会存在：许多人极度贫困，苦苦挣扎。”所以他们在很多方面都非常现代。我想，关于这一点，史学界的一场大论战始于肯尼斯·彭慕兰的一本著名书作《大分流》，他在书中论述说，发生了一些特定的物质事实，尤其是煤炭的使用。他对煤炭的使用非常推崇。中国人几个世纪前就发明了所有这些工艺，但西方对煤炭的使用推动了世界技术的发展。突然之间，我们实现了飞跃。
We can't have a society where a lot of people are really poor and barely hang on. So they were so modern in many ways. And I think, you know, the big argument about this historiographically, it started with a famous book by Kenneth Pomerantz called The Great Divergence, in which he argued there were certain material facts that happened, and especially the use of coal. He's very hot on the use of coal. Chinese had invented all these processes centuries before, but the use of coal in the West pushed world development of technologies of technologies. And suddenly, we made a leap
而这种飞跃得益于一个事实：历史上第一次，西欧这些小型、机动、具侵略性的海上商业强权能够横渡世界，征服整个新世界，剥夺其绝大多数因疾病而死的人口，掠夺其自然资源。在某种程度上，这是一种突如其来的历史巧合，不是吗？而那些依然在维护这种审慎、治理良好的秩序的中国人，突然发现自己面对的是这群新人。我认为这是一个极好的切入点，可以让我们休息一下，但也正好奠定了这样一种观念：
forward. And that leap was helped by the fact that for the first time in history, these small, mobile, aggressive maritime commercial powers in Western Europe could go out across the world, conquer the entire new world, dispossess its population, most of whom died of disease, plunder its natural resources. And it's a sudden historical happenstance in some ways, isn't it? And the Chinese, who were still maintaining this careful, well-governed order, suddenly found themselves with these new people. I think that's a brilliant note on which to take a break, but just as kind of setting up the idea
中国拥有令人难以置信的文化自信。我猜，这就是“中央帝国”吧。当乔治三世的特使马戛尔尼勋爵到来时，他带来了工业革命的全部成果。中国人并不感兴趣，因为谁是蛮族？谁会对蛮族带来的东西感兴趣呢？但我猜，19和20世纪的历史（我们在休息后会探讨）实际上是一部中国如何觉醒的历史，
that China has this incredible cultural self-confidence, I guess, it's the Middle Kingdom when Lord McCartney, George III's emissary turns up, bury all the fruits of the Industrial Revolution. The Chinese aren't interested because who's a barbarian? Who's interested in what barbarians are bringing? But I guess that the history of the 19th and 20th centuries, which we'll look at after the break, is really the history of how the Chinese wake up
他们意识到外部世界确实有他们需要学习的东西，以及他们是如何应对这一点的。所以我们将在休息后讨论这些。欲了解更多节目并抢先获得现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余烬》，我是多米尼克·桑德布鲁克，同行的还有汤姆·霍兰，以及我们今天的嘉宾伟大的迈克尔·伍德。汤姆，这一切最令人汗颜的是，在听迈克尔讲述的时候，我意识到自己对所有这些事情的了解是多么匮乏。你对这些了解得更多吗？我对第一皇帝很有兴趣，不出所料，还有早期中国与希腊化王国之间可能的联系，然后是与罗马以及丝绸之路的联系。
to the fact that the outside world does have things that it needs to learn and how it has dealt with that. So we will come to that after the break. For more episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History with me, Dominic Sandbrook, and Tom Holland, and our guest today, the great Michael Wood. Tom, the shaming thing about all this is, as Michael's been talking, I'm conscious of just how little I know about all of this kind of stuff. Are you more clued up? I'm very interested in the first emperor, predictably, and about possible links between early China and Hellenistic kingdoms and then with Rome and then the Silk Roads.
但我对中国现代史知之甚少。当我写《多米尼恩》时，我确实不得不研究耶稣会士前往中国的历史。正如我们在休息前所谈到的，相比于耶稣会士从罗马或西班牙等地看到的景象，中国文明是多么令人目瞪口呆。他们去到那里，然后说：“这是一个独一无二的地方。”他们给上级写信说：“我们不能像对待印第安人那样对待中国人。
But modern Chinese history, I know very little about. I did have to study about the Jesuits going to China when I wrote Dominion. And what we were talking about just before the break about just how stupefying Chinese civilization was compared to what the Jesuits had seen coming from Rome or from Spain or whatever. And they go there and they say, you know, this is a place like nowhere else. And they're writing back to their superiors and saying, you know, we can't treat the Chinese like we treated the Indians.
或者说，这些人是地球上最sophisticated（成熟老练/精致）的人。我们需要非常非常谨慎地行事。”公平地说，耶稣会士确实做到了，并取得了非凡的效果。我想，这与19世纪的区别在于，当英国人带着他们的炮艇气势汹汹地闯进来时，
Or, you know, these are the most sophisticated people on the face of the planet. And we need to tread very, very carefully, which, to be be fair to the Jesuits they did with kind of remarkable effect um and I guess that the difference between that and the 19th century is that when the British come blundering in with their gunboats yeah um they are in a position to scorn what they see as kind of backwardness although I think even in the 18th century they're really touching the way that Dr Johnson who you think of as kind of backwardness. Although I think even in the 18th century, they're really touching the way that Dr. Johnson, who you think of as kind of the embodiment of John Bull, you know, the man who lives in London most of his life, it's his great dream to see the Great Wall of China.
他们有底气去鄙视他们眼中那种落后——尽管我认为，甚至在18世纪，他们也对这一点赞赏有加。比如你认为集英国精神之大成的约翰逊博士，他一生大部分时间都住在伦敦，但他最大的梦想就是去看万里长城。
And he urges Boswell to take a trip. He says, yes, you must go. And when you come back, you will be known as the man who saw the Great Wall of China. Maybe he wasn't just desperate to get rid of Boswell. But all the philistines, you know, Voltaire and everybody, they're obsessed with China. They see China as the kind of the archetype of how to run a modern, sophisticated, liberal, enlightened state. So it's kind of such a contrast with what then happens in the 19th century. So Michael, can we just talk about the Opium Wars? So for people who don't know,
他敦促博斯韦尔去旅行。他说：“是的，你一定要去。等你回来后，你就会被称为‘那个看过万里长城的人’。”也许他并不只是急着想摆脱博斯韦尔。但所有的势利小人，你知道的，伏尔泰和所有人，都对中国痴迷。他们把中国视为如何运作一个现代、sophisticated、自由、开明的国家的原型。所以这与19世纪发生的事情形成了巨大的对比。那么迈克尔，我们能谈谈鸦片战争吗？对于那些不知道的人来说，
the Opium Wars were in the 1830s, 40s and then 1850s, 60s. It was British gunboats sort of blasting the Chinese in an attempt to open up China to our merchant ships, basically selling opium. We want to sell them dope and we're going to pummel them until they agree to do it. And that's something that really has left this legacy in China, hasn't it? This very divisive legacy. Am I right in thinking that we're basically, I mean, people perceive us as the baddies. Is that right? We were the bad guys and they were the victims? Well, it's how they tell it in China.
鸦片战争发生在1830年代、40年代以及1850年代、60年代。英国炮艇轰炸中国人，试图强行打开中国市场以迎接我们的商船，基本上就是为了兜售鸦片。我们想向他们推销毒品，并且要痛击他们，直到他们同意这么做。这在中国留下了历史遗产，不是吗？这种极具分裂性的遗产。我没想错的话，基本上——我的意思是，人们把我们视为坏人。是这样吗？我们是坏人，而他们是受害人？好吧，这正是他们在中国讲述这个故事的方式。
But the number of Chinese friends of mine, including scholars, are exasperated by this. And they go, oh, God, this victim narrative. The Chinese government are just going to drop it. Can't we revise the bloody curriculum? You know, this victim stuff is just so out of date. Every dynasty rises and falls. And when at the moment the dynasty is starting to come apart, there's a catalyst for the next period of rebirth.
但我的许多中国朋友（包括学者）对此感到非常恼火。他们说：“哦，天哪，这种受害者叙事。中国政府真该抛弃它了。难道我们不能修改一下该死的课程吗？这种受害者心态实在是太陈旧了。每个朝代都在兴起和衰落。当这个朝代开始走向解体时，正是下一次重生的催化剂。”
Right. And the Brits were the catalyst. And the new China starts to be made in Shanghai in the 1860s when they're building the HSBC and all that. But it is a brutal time. I mean, if you just backtrack a slight, just a few moments before the Opium War, Tom mentioned the McCartney expedition of 1793. And China had had 100 years of amazing achievements in civilization and governance. I think three great rulers, all of them long-lived and long-ruling.
没错。英国人就是那个催化剂。现代中国开始在1860年代的上海逐渐成型，当时他们在建造汇丰银行以及其他设施。但这确实是一个残酷的时代。我的意思是，如果你把时间稍微倒回一点，就在鸦片战争前不久，汤姆提到了1793年的马戛尔尼使团。当时中国在文明和治理方面已经经历了100年的惊人成就。我想这归功于三位伟大的统治者，他们都长寿且在位时间长。
They ruled between them for about 130 years. I can't remember the exact number. And the old Qianlong was still on the throne when the Brits came. And when you look at McCartney's diary of that expedition, the Brits are very impressed by many of the things that they see. And they can see that this is a great polity which has existed for a very, very long time. You've got to remember in the British mind, there are geopolitics which the Chinese don't really understand.
他们共同统治了大约130年。具体数字我记不清了。英国人来的时候，老乾隆还在位。如果你看马戛尔尼对那次远征的日记，英国人对他们看到的很多东西印象深刻。他们能看出这是一个已经存在了非常非常长时间的伟大政治实体。你必须记住，在英国人的脑海中，存在着中国人并不真正理解的地缘政治。
A lot of Chinese writers at that time say, we just don't know enough of what's going on. The Brits had lost their colonies in America. The Brits at almost the same time had won their victories in South India and Bengal, and with the, you know, the likes of Clive of India. And so suddenly, the Brits have an international empire. And at the very moment that they've lost their purchase in the Americas to a degree, they find this extraordinary new wealth in India, all of which is protected by small amounts of British troops
当时很多中国作家说，我们只是对正在发生的事情了解不够。英国人在美洲失去了殖民地。几乎在同时，英国人在南印度和孟加拉国取得了胜利，借助了诸如“印度之克莱夫”这样的人物。因此，英国人突然拥有了一个国际帝国。正当他们在美洲的影响力在某种程度上减弱时，他们在印度发现了这种非凡的新财富，所有这些都由少量的英国军队
and large amounts of Indian troops. And the trade with China has started to grow up. It's another of those triangles, like the slave triangle. And the British economy, by the 1790s, had started to become dependent on China through the triangle with India. And they're selling opium to China and they get it bringing textiles. Is that because opium is the only thing that the Chinese are interested in buying off the British? Well, I think there was a long trade in it. Opium's grown in India especially, and it was one of those things
和大量的印度军队保护着。与中国的贸易开始发展起来。这是又一个那样的三角贸易，就像奴隶三角贸易一样。到18世纪90年代，英国经济已经通过与印度的三角贸易开始依赖中国。他们向中国出售鸦片，并用它换取纺织品。这是因为鸦片是唯一引起英国人购买兴趣的中国商品吗？嗯，我认为这有一个长期的贸易过程。鸦片主要产于印度，这是那些
that these freelance merchants, you know, because this is the same East India company that's been doing its best in India, you know. So it's one of the things that they realise they can extract a lot out of China with. And McCartney, but McCartney goes in order to open up official trade. What they want to do is regularize the trade. They want to establish an island base, as Hong Kong would eventually be, from which they could trade year-round rather than go on these very, very limited and highly controlled contacts around Macau and stuff like that.
自由职业商人所意识到的事情之一，你知道的，因为这和在印度尽最大努力的东印度公司是同一家公司。所以这是他们意识到可以从中从中国榨取很多东西的事情之一。而马戛尔尼，但马戛尔尼此行是为了打开官方贸易。他们想做的是将贸易常规化。他们想建立一个岛屿基地，就像后来的香港那样，他们可以在那里进行全年贸易，而不是像在澳门周围那样进行非常非常有限且高度控制的接触。
So they want full ambassador status in Beijing. So these are the things they want, the trade, the ambassador, the island offshore. That's what they're looking for. And as you say, they take with them all the great achievements of modern British manufacture, you know, Birmingham astronomical equipment, astrolabes and horariums, and along with, you know, Birmingham arms manufacturers stuff as well. And although when Qianlong looks at it, he does that famous line,
所以他们希望在北京获得全权大使的地位。所以这些是他们想要的：贸易、大使、离岸岛屿。这就是他们所寻求的。正如你所说，他们随身带去了现代英国制造业的所有伟大成就，你知道的，伯明翰的天文设备、星盘和计时仪，还有，你知道的，伯明翰的武器制造商的东西。尽管乾隆看到这些时，他说出了那句名言，
you know, these kind of things would not be of interest to a child. You know, we are, as you can see, we are China. We are self-sufficient in everything. We do not need your Western toys. But actually, they were really interested in the military stuff. And you could see that they could see that the Westerners had a real edge on this. So McCartney is very, he's a bit deflated by the failure to get what he'd hoped for, because he sees China as a really great civilization. And he sees the British with their
你知道的，这些东西小孩子都不会感兴趣。你知道的，正如你所见，我们是大中国。我们在各方面都自给自足。我们不需要你们的西方玩具。但实际上，他们对军事方面的东西非常感兴趣。你可以看出他们能看出西方人在这方面确实有优势。因此，马戛尔尼感到非常，由于未能达到他所希望的目标，他有点泄气，因为他将中国视为一个真正的伟大文明。他看到英国人有着
open mindedness, their sense of fairness and justice and legality. He thinks the proper trading relationships between the two countries will be of great advantage to China, because he understands that this guy, McCartney, had been, you know, he'd been governor in South India, he'd been ambassador extraordinary to Russia, he'd been in the Caribbean. He's the guy who invents the phrase, the empire on which the sun never sets. This guy, among all the diplomats of the world, had a sense of the future. And he understood that China needed to modernize. And he thought the Brits could be that catalyst. So they're not patronizing, even though, of course, when he writes up in his diary later,
开放的思维、公平正义和法治的观念。他认为两国之间正确的贸易关系将对中国大有裨益，因为他明白这个人——马戛尔尼，曾担任过南印度总督，曾任驻俄罗斯特命全权大使，曾在加勒比海工作过。他就是那个发明“日不落帝国”这一短语的人。这个人，在全世界的外交官中，具有对未来的洞察力。他明白中国需要现代化。他认为英国人可以成为那种催化剂。所以他们并不是居高临下的，尽管当然，当他在日记中写到时，
he says, the thing about China is, it's like a crazy old man of war, like a huge ancient three-decked galleon that a succession of gifted captains have managed to keep afloat for all this time. But the fact is it's in trouble now. It's going to be in trouble. It cannot be rebuilt on the same keel and and you it's these breezy nautical metaphors that the brits use you know and and and eventually if it doesn't change it will despite the gifted captains who have steered it it will end up on the rocks
他说，关于中国，它的情况就像一艘疯狂的老式战舰，就像一艘巨大的古代三层甲板大帆船，历任才华横溢的船长设法让它漂浮了这么长时间。但事实是它现在有麻烦了。它将会陷入麻烦。它不能在同一个龙骨上重建，而且，你知道的，这些轻快的航海隐喻是英国人使用的，你知道的，而且最终，如果它不改变，尽管有引导它的才华横溢的船长，它最终还是会触礁。
so it's a it's a fantastically brilliant moment. And when the Chinese, but of course the Chinese rebuff him, and that's what leads to the Opium War, because the Brits carry on trading illegally with the dealers on the shores of China, the lonely ports along the coast of Fujian, and it gets worse and worse until the Chinese in the 1830s say, we can't have this anymore and we're stopping the trade. And that's when the Brits take action because, as McCartney said,
所以这是一个非常精彩的时刻。当中国人，但当然中国人拒绝了他，这就导致了鸦片战争，因为英国人继续与中国海岸的经销商、福建海岸边远港口的那些人进行非法贸易，情况变得越来越糟，直到19世纪30年代中国官员说，我们不能再这样下去了，我们要停止贸易。正是在那时，英国人采取了行动，因为正如马戛尔尼所说，
if the trade were to stop, the blow to the textile industries in the north of England and indeed to our whole national economy would be so great that the nation would be rocked by it. Michael, this idea of China as a kind of fortress, you know, the Great Wall of China is the emblem of that, keeping ambassadors, traders, whatever, absolutely on the periphery. That's the place for them. There's also a sense of anxiety about ideological infection, isn't there? So the Jesuits, when they go, a kind of, you know, constant process of negotiation.
如果贸易停止，对英格兰北部纺织业乃至我们整个国民经济的打击将是如此巨大，以至于整个国家都将为此受到震撼。迈克尔，中国作为某种堡垒的这种想法，你知道的，中国长城就是它的象征，把大使、商人或其他什么人绝对地限制在边缘。那是他们的地方。对于意识形态的感染也有一种焦虑，不是吗？所以耶稣会士去的时候，也是一个，你知道的，不断谈判的过程。
There's an anxiety about what the effect of Christian missionaries might be, which brings us to a question from William Ritchie, who asks, is it possible to think that if the Taiping Rebellion had succeeded, China would have had a better and more peaceful transition to modernity. Because basically, have I got this right? The Taiping Rebellion is the customary Chinese breakdown, but with Christian millennial fantasies. And also incredibly, incredibly bloody. So the Taiping Rebellion, more people died in the Taiping Rebellion in World War One. Isn't that right, Michael? Some people think. Yeah. So Michael, is the Taiping Rebellion the result of a fusion of traditional kind of Chinese splintering of an empire, which happens periodically, with these new Christian ideas? Or is it something that just kind of blows up? So we're talking, what, 1840s?
人们对于基督教传教士可能产生的影响感到焦虑，这把我们带到了威廉·里奇（William Ritchie）的一个问题，他问：我们是否可以认为，如果太平天国运动成功了，中国走向现代化的过渡会更好、更和平？因为基本上，我理解得对吗？太平天国运动是习以为常的中国崩溃，但带有基督教千禧年幻想。而且极其、极其血腥。所以太平天国运动，太平天国运动中死去的人比第一次世界大战还要多。不是这样的吗，迈克尔？有些人是这么认为的。是的。那么迈克尔，太平天国运动是传统的中国帝国分裂（这种分裂周期性发生）与这些新的基督教思想融合的结果吗？还是某种突然爆发的东西？所以我们在谈论，什么，18世纪40年代？
Through the 40s, 50s to the mid-60s. Yeah, 16 years. 16 years, the Taiping. And it's an unbelievable story, like so many in the story of China. You know, this rebel ex-student who'd been a failure in life, who believes he is the chosen of the Christian God and he's God's Chinese son, and recruits an army of the disaffected in the south, takes the capital, the great Ming capital of Nanjing,
贯穿40年代、50年代到60年代中期。是的，16年。16年，太平天国。这是一个令人难以置信的故事，就像中国历史上的许多故事一样。你知道的，这个曾经在生活中失意的叛逆前学生，他相信自己是基督教上帝的选民，是上帝的中国儿子，并在南方招募了一支心怀不满的军队，攻占了首都——伟大的明朝首都南京，
the southern capital, and institutes a reign of terror in some ways. And in some ways it's similar to the communists in the communist era, terrifying social laws and punishments. It's a really grim moment, but it's an absolutely crucial moment in the story of China. I don't think China's transition to modernity would have been helped if the Taiping had won. But it's one of those forecasts.
南方首都，并在某些方面实行了恐怖统治。在某些方面，它类似于共产主义时期的共产党，有着可怕的社会法律和惩罚。这是一个非常严峻的时刻，但它是中国历史上的一个绝对关键的时刻。我不认为如果太平天国赢了，中国向现代化的过渡会得到帮助。但这是那些预测之一。
I mean, really, I was looking it up, actually, and between the Opium War in 1911, there are major peasant uprisings every single year in China. So the disaffection starts to grow once the government has lost its control over the center. The center will not hold. That's what you can see the period of dissolution, dissolution, which starts then. The opium war kind of triggers it. And the Taiping comes after the opium war and lasts for 16 years.
我的意思是，实际上，我查了一下，在1840年鸦片战争到1911年之间，中国每年都会发生重大的农民起义。因此，一旦政府失去了对中央的控制，这种不满情绪就开始增长。中央无法稳固。这就是你可以看到的解体时期的开始，也就是从那时开始的。鸦片战争在某种程度上引发了它。而太平天国发生在鸦片战争之后，持续了16年。
And from then on, the ruling classes in China are on the back foot. And many great thinkers are arguing we have to modernize now. We have to adopt Western technology. We have to build Western naval dockyards. They start to talk about introducing the railways. But at the center of this was the imperial system, and essentially the imperial system was still descended from the Ming and the Qing, and the emperor is still going on the midwinter solstice to the altar of heaven in the south of Beijing, and performing effectively Bronze Age rituals to the cosmos. And while people, increasingly Western educated intellectuals are saying, we need to change all this. You know, can we have a constitutional monarchy? We should have
从那时起，中国的统治阶级就处于守势。许多伟大的思想家都在争辩说，我们现在必须现代化。我们必须采用西方技术。我们必须建造西方海军船坞。他们开始谈论引进铁路。但这一切的核心是帝制，本质上帝制仍然是从明清传承下来的，皇帝在冬至那天仍然要去北京南郊的天坛，对宇宙进行实际上是青铜器时代的仪式。而当人们，越来越多受过西方教育的知识分子在说，我们需要改变这一切。你知道的，我们可以实行君主立宪制吗？我们应该有
regional assemblies. We should have this. We should have that. By the 1880s, you got feminists starting to emerge by the same time as the suffragettes, manifestos on women's liberation. When did any of us know about any of this? Extraordinary. So it's a ferment, an absolute ferment of ideas. But the overthrow of the imperial system is going to be the first thing. And then the question is, how do we truly modernize? And that's where the communists come in and the many other movements
地方议会。我们应该有这个。我们应该有那个。到19世纪80年代，你开始看到女权主义者与女权运动者同时出现，关于妇女解放的宣言也随之产生。我们当中有谁知道这些吗？非同寻常。所以这是一个思想的酝酿期，一个绝对的酝酿期。但推翻帝制将是第一件事。然后问题是，我们如何真正实现现代化？这就是共产党人发挥作用的地方，还有许多其他运动
who were after the reform of society at the lower level where 80, 90% of the people still worked in the fields and the rural problem becomes absolutely central in the 20th century. But that's a rough trajectory.
他们追求在底层对社会进行改革，当时80%、90%的人仍然在田间劳作，农村问题在20世纪变得绝对核心。但这大致是一个轨迹。
It feels as if the world starts to change in the 1830s and then the opium wars and what happens afterwards intensify it at the same time there's a wonderful account of china written in the 1840s by a french traveler a jesuit who um sorry, not a Jesuit. I think he was Francis. Anyway, he's a Catholic priest, Père Gabé, who spoke Chinese. And he writes an account of China saying this is still the most, the greatest civilization on earth. It's still the best governed.
感觉世界在1830年代开始发生变化，然后鸦片战争以及随后的事件加剧了这种变化。与此同时，有一份关于中国的精彩记录，由一位法国旅行者、一位耶稣会士在1840年代撰写，他嗯，抱歉，不是耶稣会士。我想他是方济各会士。总之，他是一位天主教神父——加贝神父（Père Gabé），他会说中文。他写了一份关于中国的记录，称这仍然是世界上最伟大、最伟大的文明。它仍然是治理得最好的。
They still have systems of local governance, local charity, and he talks about all these things, which would, you know, surpass anything we've got in the West. We Westerners shouldn't patronize this civilization. It may have come down with these archaic forms of rule, but its effectiveness, when you travel through China, you see the standard of living in the villages. So, you know, I suspect there's a lot more to be learned about these struggles in the 19th century. So, Michael, to fast forward for a bit, you then have this period, which is just a complete nightmare of warlords and occupation by the Japanese, obviously, and sort of rival groups and millions of people dying.
他们仍然拥有地方治理、地方慈善系统，他谈到了所有这些事情，你知道的，这些将超越我们在西方拥有的任何东西。我们西方人绝不应该以居高临下的态度对待这个文明。它可能带有这些陈旧的统治形式，但它的效力，当你游历中国时，你会看到村庄里的生活水平。所以，你知道的，我怀疑关于19世纪这些斗争还有更多东西需要了解。所以，迈克尔，快进一会儿，然后你就会经历这段时期，这完全是一场军阀混战和日本侵略的噩梦，显然，还有各种敌对派别和数百万人死亡。
And the big winners are the communists, 1949, the revolution, obviously, and sort of rival groups and millions of people dying. And the big winners are the communists, 1949, the revolution, Mao, and then the rest of the story is probably more familiar to a lot of our listeners. Why is it that the communists won? Is it because they were offering, is it a bit like the Russian Civil War after the First World War where the communists won because the other warlords were just offering sort of warlordism? Obviously, the communists were offering land reform. We had a question from Stephen Clark saying,
最大的赢家是共产党人，1949年，革命，当然还有各种敌对派别和数百万人的死亡。最大的赢家是共产党人，1949年的革命，毛泽东，然后故事的其余部分可能对我们的许多听众来说更熟悉。为什么共产党会赢？是因为他们提供的吗，这有点像第一次世界大战后的俄国内战，共产党之所以获胜，是因为其他军阀提供的只是一种军阀统治？显然，共产党提供了土地改革。我们有一个来自斯蒂芬·克拉克（Stephen Clark）的问题，他说：
is it all about land reform? Is that their positive vision that explains it, or is it aid from Russia or just contingency or what? Yeah, in some ways it's contingency. There's a famous story of Chairman Mao after the revolution talking to the Japanese ambassador who actually apologized for the Japanese act during the invasion and occupation and from the 36 37 through to the end of the war and Mao said don't apologize I wouldn't be here today without you
这一切都是关于土地改革吗？这是他们能够解释这一切的积极愿景吗，还是来自俄罗斯的援助，或者是纯粹的偶然性，还是别的什么？是的，在某些方面是偶然性。有一个著名的故事，毛主席在革命后与日本大使交谈，日本大使实际上为日本在侵华和占领期间的行为道歉，从36、37年一直到战争结束，毛主席说不要道歉，如果没有你们，我今天就不会站在这里。
and you know so the Japanese invasion was a major, major intrusion. You know, if you remember what had happened, that the communists had been attacked by the nationalist government of China in their heartland in the south in Hunan, and they had to escape the encirclement, where thousands of people have been killed by the nationalists, they embarked on this 6,000-mile great curving journey up to the north to Yan'an called the Long March. And there they established their base, and they got their base right at the moment the Japanese invade. And so for the next few years, they controlled that zone around Yan'an. And they
你知道的，所以日本侵华是一个重大、重大的干涉。你知道，如果你还记得发生过什么，中国国民党曾在他们的腹地湖南袭击了共产党，他们不得不逃离包围圈，成千上万的人被国民党杀害，他们踏上了这条长达6000英里、向北蜿蜒曲折到达延安的伟大征程，被称为“长征”。正是在那里，他们建立了基地，而且他们的基地刚好在日本侵华的那个时刻建立。所以在接下来的几年里，他们控制了延安周边的那个地带。他们
instituted land reforms and all sorts of changes there. And won quite, at that stage, won quite a lot of credit in the eyes of the ordinary population. There's a wonderful diary published fairly recently by an ordinary bloke, a kind of schoolteacher, mine manager, two-bit farmer living in a dismal coal mining town not far from Beijing, Taiwan. And he's having these conversations with his friend who's a Buddhist monk up in the hills. Oh, the communist guerrillas have done this to the Japanese. And there's a feeling that the communists are patriots.
在那里实行了土地改革和各种变革。在那个阶段，在普通民众眼中赢得了相当多的信誉。最近出版了一本非常精彩的日记，作者是一个普通人，一个类似于学校老师、矿山经理、住在离北京不远的暗淡煤矿小镇里的二流农民——台湾（注：此处指戴望舒或特定回忆录人物，译文直译）。他正在和他在山上的佛教僧侣朋友进行这些交谈。哦，中国共产党游击队对日本人做了这个。有一种感觉，即共产党是爱国者。
But essentially we support what they're doing, even though their ideology is alien to either the Buddhist monk friend or the old mine manager who's still a Confucian. He still believes in the old values of imperial China. So they got a lot of support then. And I think after the horrors of the Japanese invasion and the Second World War, and you think of the losses, Chinese losses in the Second World War, we forget they were our ally. You know, they're the fourth ally.
但本质上我们支持他们所做的事情，尽管他们的意识形态对佛教僧侣朋友或仍然是儒家信徒的老矿经理来说是格格不入的。他仍然相信中国古代帝国的价值观。所以他们当时得到了很多支持。而且我认为，在经历了日本侵华和第二次世界大战的恐怖之后，想想中国在第二次世界大战中的损失，我们常常忘记他们曾是我们的盟友。你知道的，他们是第四大盟国。
And Chinese resistance against Japan was a massive factor in victory in the Pacific War. And so I think the moment came when the communists could gather huge support at the end of the Second World War as a patriotic liberation front. And they swept down the country and achieved their victory. October 1949, the republics declared. And in a sense, it's a historical chance. And what happened afterwards is still highly contested,
中国对日本的抵抗是太平洋战争胜利的一个巨大因素。因此我认为，在第二次世界大战结束时，共产党作为爱国解放阵线，迎来了可以汇聚巨大支持的时刻。他们横扫全国并取得了胜利。1949年10月，共和国宣告成立。从某种意义上说，这是一种历史的偶然。而后来发生的事情仍然饱受争议，
and the Chinese government at the moment is being very tight-arsed about any criticism of Mao. You know, President Xi recently made a speech saying it has been accustomed to divide the period between pre-1976, the death of Mao, and post. But we say there is no division. It is an organic kind of whole, you know. And any discussion of historic mistakes we no longer want, you know, because the Communist Party after Mao's death had actually said that Chairman Mao was a great leader, but he made massive historical mistakes.
中国政府目前对任何批评毛泽东的言论都非常严厉。你知道的，习近平主席最近发表了一次讲话，称习惯于将1976年（毛泽东逝世）前后的时期割裂开来。但我们说没有割裂。这是一个有机的整体，你知道的。对于历史错误的任何讨论，我们不再想要，你知道的，因为共产党在毛泽东死后实际上曾说过，毛主席是一位伟大的领袖，但他犯了巨大的历史错误。
And he mistook the people for the enemy and right from wrong. And therein lies his tragedy. This is a Communist Party, said he in 1981. And President Xi is now saying, we do not accept that. So what happened in the 1950s as things gradually turned, the assault on the landowning landlord classes, then the Great Leap Forward, then the Cultural Revolution, all that the Chinese government is now trying to really play down.
他把人民当作敌人，混淆了是非。这正是他的悲剧所在。这是一个共产党，他在1981年这样说过。而习近平主席现在说，我们不接受这一点。所以随着情况逐渐转变，50年代发生的事情——对地主阶级的打击，然后是大跃进，然后是文化大革命——所有这些，中国政府现在都正试图极力淡化。
There actually was an attempt pushed under President Xi to have a commemoration of the Cultural Revolution. Oh, my word. And leading people within the Communist Party stamped on it and said, we can't be doing that. And hence you get this fantastic verdict by one party insider who said if chairman ma had died in 1956 he would be seen as an immortal if he died in 1966 we would still see him as a great man if flawed and having made some terrible decisions but he died in 1976 alas
实际上，在习近平主席的推动下，曾试图举行纪念文化大革命的活动。哦，天哪。共产党内的领导人物对此进行了打压，并表示我们不能这样做。因此，你从一位党内知情人士那里得到了一个极妙的评价，他说，如果毛主席在1956年去世，他将被视为不朽；如果他在1966年去世，我们仍然会认为他是一个伟大的人，尽管有缺陷并做出了一些可怕的决定；但他死于1976年，唉，
what is there to say wow just i think i think that our ambition to cover the whole sweep of chinese history in under an hour is doomed to fail so i think we need to could i just have one one question which will which will tie in with, try and bundle this in, the communist period with everything that's gone before. What is Xi's attitude to the pre-communist state, to the emperors? In China now, the Communist Party,
还有什么好说的呢？哇，我觉得，我觉得我们想在不到一个小时的时间里涵盖中国历史的全貌注定是要失败的。所以我认为我们需要，我能只问一个问题吗？这个问题将把共产党时期与之前发生的一切串联、捆绑在一起。习近平对待前共产主义国家、对待皇帝的态度是什么？现在的中国，共产党，
is there pride in that? Is there a sense of continuity? Yeah, there absolutely is. President Xi has made a plank, one of the planks of the current regime's stance in the world as the greatness of Chinese civilization. He's actually been quoted in a wraparound for a new version of Confucius, you know, saying, you know, we should all read this text. It's absolutely essential to Chinese history. And he is a great reader of history. And, I mean, we had an interesting thing on this. You know, my book comes out of a series of films we made called The Story of China.
对此有自豪感吗？有一种延续感吗？是的，绝对有。习近平主席将中国文明的伟大作为当前政权在世界上的立场支柱之一。他在一个新版本《论语》（或孔子语录）的封套上被引用，你知道的，他说，我们都应该阅读这本书。它对中国历史绝对至关重要。他是一个狂热的历史读者。我的意思是，我们在这方面有一段有趣的经历。你知道的，我的书源于我们制作的一系列名为《中国的故事》的纪录片。
And these films were within hours available online in China with Chinese translations of them, even though there's stuff at the end of Tiananmen Square and all that, which fairly rapidly got cut out. And we got a really big response. And we were interviewed by, you know, I was interviewed by China Daily and Xinhua News, People's Daily, all this sort of stuff. And President Xi, in a big conference about the media and television
这些电影在几个小时内就在中国网上上线了，配有中文翻译，尽管片尾有关于天安门广场的内容和其他东西，这些内容很快就被删掉了。我们得到了非常热烈的反响。我们接受了采访，你知道的，我接受了《中国日报》、新华社、《人民日报》所有这些媒体的采访。习近平主席在一次关于媒体、电视
and history, talked about our films and said, I'm not sure this is something I particularly want to advertise, Dominic, in the interest of history on a great historical podcast. And he said that these Brits had done this series called The Story of China. And it was very interesting and they did a very good job, he said. But we need to tell the story of china and they and it was very interesting and they did a very good job he said uh but we need to tell the story of china better we need to tell it better so we must we must learn from these these filmmakers and um that's been a real working as some somebody works in film that's been a really interesting dimension to this they're they're pretty obsessive about their history i did a film last year about the great poet dufu um fabulous
和历史的大型会议上，谈到了我们的纪录片，并说，我不确定这是否是我特别想要宣传的东西，多米尼克，从伟大历史播客的历史利益出发。他说，这些英国人制作了这个名为《中国的故事》的系列片。这非常有趣，他们做得很好，他说。但我们需要讲好中国的故事，他们——这非常有趣，他们做得很好，他说，呃，但我们需要更好地讲述中国的故事，我们需要更好地讲述它，所以我们必须向这些电影制作人学习，呃，对于一个从事电影工作的人来说，这一直是一个非常有趣的维度。他们对自己的历史有着相当程度的痴迷。我去年拍了一部关于伟大诗人杜甫的电影，
film batang dynasty poet and friends in friend again it went online within hours in china and friends in beijing phoned me up on a monday morning saying you're not going to believe this but the central commission for discipline of Communist Party, which is the most powerful commission in the communist government. They run the ruthless anti-corruption campaign that President Xi is doing. You know, they're the people who do Bo Xilai and all these people and lock them up. And they've got an editorial page on their website saying there's been this very about Dufu. And, you know, the questions that arise from it are about Confucian ethics and Dufu's loyalty to the state and Dufu's this, that, and the other. And the question we have to ask is, why have we failed
一部极好的唐代诗人的电影，再次在几小时内就在中国的网络上上线了，我在北京的朋友在星期一早上打电话给我说，你绝对不会相信这个，共产党中央纪律检查委员会——这是共产政府中最强大的委员会。他们负责习近平主席正在进行的严厉反腐败运动。你知道的，他们负责处理薄熙来和所有这些人并把他们关起来。他们的网站上有一篇社论版，说有一部关于杜甫的非常……你知道的，由此产生的问题是关于儒家伦理、杜甫对国家的忠诚以及杜甫的这个那个。我们必须问的问题是，为什么我们在反腐败运动中失败了？
in our anti-corruption drive? Why? And the answer is that unlike D doofoo our party cadres have not internalized these essential confusion virtues of civility and blah blah you know and loyalty to the state and uh and and our friends in beijing were just thought this was hilarious you know that uh that even the party themselves were saying you know what do we learn from history? Because there are great dangers in Chinese history. You will be pleased on your podcast, of course, that history, as you know, is potent. The first emperor buried the historians alive
为什么？答案是，与杜甫不同，我们的党政干部没有将这些基本的儒家美德内化，比如文明、啦啦啦（你知道的）以及对国家的忠诚，呃，呃，我们在北京的朋友只是觉得这太滑稽了，你知道的，甚至党自己也在说，你知道我们从历史中学到了什么？因为中国历史上有巨大的危险。你当然会高兴地在你的播客上谈到，历史，如你所知，是具有潜力的。第一个皇帝把历史学家活埋了，
and burned the history books for fear that the past might discredit the present. It's great, isn't it? It's a terrifying precedent. The past discredredit the present. It's great, isn't it? It's a terrifying precedent. The past discrediting the present, yeah. And, of course, that's the case all through Chinese history. And anybody you talk to, anybody you read, they say, well, of course, when you look back to Taizong's blah, blah, blah,
并烧毁了历史书，唯恐过去会使现在黯然失色。这太棒了，不是吗？这是一个可怕的先例。过去让现在黯然失色，这太棒了，不是吗？这是一个可怕的先例。过去让现在黯然失色，是的。而且，当然，整个中国历史都是如此。你交谈的任何人，你阅读的任何人，他们都会说，嗯，当然，当你回顾唐太宗的种种时，
everybody knows what you mean. You tell a story of gross corruption or of injustice, and everybody knows what you mean. You tell a story of gross corruption or of injustice and everybody knows what you mean. It's about a thousand years ago, but it's about now. Michael, that is an absolutely perfect note on which to end. I'm disappointed we haven't had time really to cover the communist period in Dominic. Maybe we could do another episode.
每个人都知道你的意思。你讲一个严重腐败或不公正的故事，每个人都知道你的意思。你讲一个严重腐败或不公正的故事，每个人都知道你的意思。那是大约一千年前的事，但它也是关于现在的。迈克尔，这绝对是一个完美的结束语。我很遗憾我们没有时间真正涵盖多米尼克的共产主义时期。也许我们可以做另一期节目。
Yeah. communist period and dominate maybe we could do it have it back have another episode yeah i've some focus on on um cultural revolution deng chao ping modern period all of that um but michael i can't thank you enough we we had when we announced that um we were having you as a guest we had a brilliant tweet from someone called son of york who said do you have to limit michael to china can't you get him back to talk about Anglo-Saxon England, Alexander, Troy, and so on? So, yeah, of course we could. But if we could save you up for communist China,
对，共产主义时期和多米尼克，也许我们可以再做一次，再有一集，对，我的一些重点放在文化大革命、邓小平、现代时期所有这些上，但迈克尔，我对你感激不尽。当我们宣布你将作为嘉宾时，一个叫“约克之子”（son of york）的人发了一条精彩的推文，他说：你必须把迈克尔限制在中国吗？你难道不能让他回来谈谈盎格鲁-萨克逊英格兰、亚历山大、特洛伊等等吗？所以，是的，我们当然可以。但如果我们能把你留到讲共产主义中国的时候，
yes, of course. Come on. Of course, of course. Let's get it real quick. But actually, were you to think about this in a while, the Deng Xiaoping opening up, the idea that the most eminent American sinologist said it was the greatest event in the history of the world, in modern history at least. It's something that I looked at.
是的，当然。来吧。当然，当然。让我们快点讲。但实际上，如果你有一段时间考虑这个问题，邓小平的开放，最著名的汉学家说这是世界历史上、至少是现代历史上最伟大的事件。这是我研究过的事情。
I had a chance to go two years ago back there and talk to a lot of people involved in it, including Deng Xiaoping's translator. I went to the village where the peasants first broke with the communist system at risk of lives, and interviewed two of the guys, the peasants who did it. I talked to a lot of people who had been working in the farm fields on manual labour in 78, 79, and sat the exams for the first time. And so I've got a real sense of it from the inside of what happened. Can we book you then? Yeah, you're talking yourself into more work, into more work I'd be very game to do that The question about Nixon
两年前我有机会回到那里，与许多参与其中的人交谈，包括邓小平的翻译。我去了农民们冒着生命危险率先打破共产主义体制的那个村庄，采访了其中两个这样做的人。我采访了许多在78、79年从事农业体力劳动并在田间劳作、第一次参加考试的人。所以我对所发生的事情有了真正的内部感受。我们能预约你吗？是的，你这是在给自己揽更多的工作，揽更多的工作，我非常乐意这样做。关于尼克松的问题
is really interesting but I'd say that it was Deng's visit to the state that was such an impact because Was that when he wore the cowboy hat? He wore the cowboy hat Deng Xiaoping not only went west, he went western and he goes to the rodeo. And it's all over American TV.
真的很有趣，但我得说，是邓小平访问美国才产生了如此大的影响，因为那是他戴牛仔帽的时候吗？他戴了牛仔帽，邓小平不仅向西走，而且走得更西，他去了竞技场。这登上了全美各大电视台。
And it's on Chinese TV because CCTV has just started. And you've got diaries of people saying, we've seen Deng Xiaoping on TV in America. So that is a really great story. Save it. Please save it. And we'll do the whole sweep of of post-communist well not post-communist communist china and um dan chow ping and the current state
它也在中国电视上播放，因为中央电视台刚开始播出。你有日记记载人们说，我们在美国的电视上看到了邓小平。所以这是一个非常棒的故事。留着它。请留着它。我们将讲述后共产主义——哦，不是后共产主义，是共产主义中国以及邓小平现状的整个历程。
i can't thank you enough for this tour de raison and reminder we're bringing out pods twice a week at the moment mondays and thursdays um so the next one on monday um thanks so much michael thanks dominic we will see you again next week. Thanks, Michael. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
对于这次精彩的讲解和提醒，我向你表示衷心的感谢，我们目前每周推出两次播客，在周一和周四，所以下一次是在周星期一，非常感谢迈克尔，感谢多米尼克，我们下周见。谢谢迈克尔。再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听独家节目、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。也就是 restishistorypod.com。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。